[Music]
and not a good luck news submitted by
cotton-eyed Joe the ages of Leonardo
DiCaprio's girlfriends are concerning
some people really he like some young we
all know this he does he basically how
young right when they turn like someone
over 26 as I'm sure right oh and if they
turn 27 he dumped some luck on their
birthday
really basically he don't like them old
so someone on reddit made a chart no it
says the title is Leo DiCaprio refuses
to date a woman over 25 and you can see
here Leo this is Leo's age and this is
the age of the women in the dates the
years own he dated them 18 the first one
was Gisele Bundchen when she leave when
he falls he was 18 he was 24 they dated
up until she was 23 the next one he
dated this is the one that lasted the
longest Bar Refaeli another supermodel
they dated for five years the only date
supermodels huh models and blonde and
under the age of 25
oh that makes sense at least is
consistent and most supermodels are
hella young that's why the statistics of
if you only go for student US
supermodels it's gonna they're gonna be
under that age thank you I thought we
were gonna like barely turned 18 young
they start off usually like at 20 or
like for Blake Lively she was 22 and
then she dumped him for Ryan Reynolds Oh
Blake Lively's an actress right yeah but
she also models and stuff oh I know he
did it
[Music]
they don't look 18 god damn they don't
like women for sure therefore he's a
[ __ ] it's Leo do you expect he's top
of the a-list right now yeah but this is
just so funny huh they're like Leo's age
limit
cuz as soon as they turn 25 they break
up that's great and so right now started
dating this twenty year old girl latina
43 now she's 21
so he's 44 is there something wrong with
that though we wait so how long how long
how long is he staying with
before if there are five years of the
longest with this chick from 20 to 25
but if she's 18 he can probably stay we
got a little longer but if you start at
23 then they'd only two years yeah damn
you for him to even stay with anyone for
five years is pretty crazy
oh no Gisele use whatever six years from
18 to 23
I couldn't believe George Clooney got
married I know he was forever dog player
like so he's finally settling down at
like 90 years old right yes window and
then his wife is like [ __ ] dope yeah
his wife's like cool cool chick who does
a bunch of charity work or whatever a
lawyer no humans right yeah human rights
attorney or some leo does crazy amount
of charity to try to save the planet
yeah but he dates young chicks too
though ha so [ __ ] him right don't models
get scouted and like big when they're
hella young like 16 or 17 or whatever 15
16 15 16 right so then they start the
career hella early and then by the time
they're like 20 they're like mega models
yeah yeah but a lot of times too when
you're not like super famous famous like
household names you get drop it like 20
something that's when you're concerned
old 22 told you if you consistently like
you're a nobody like Victoria's Secret
grow or whatever because you start
living off your name your life I'm so
not only Campbell's still modeling where
she wow that's [ __ ] jay-z kills it
black don't crack do she looks good
Tyree just sits Sports Illustrated a
couple weeks ago to transition her
career though to being more like a like
a like a host and all these other things
she was a little bit of everything for a
longest time because she had the TV show
for forever - dude I'm so sick of people
shaming middle-aged men because they
like them young okay well his most
recent girlfriend so with her they
started dating when or like they met
when she was 19 and then they started
dating six months later she was 20 but
she happens to be a former stepdaughter
of Al Pacino - so then they're saying
that like he knew her when she was like
11 or something so that is like creeping
baby
I don't think so because if you know
someone when they're 11 they look 11 and
then when you see them when they're 25
there are different persons or a
completely yeah well it's not like their
family's weird if it's family right and
how often did he see that it's like if
if Isaac aged up what if I dated Isaac
the money see yeah but that's like
family though like how close are they
there are they going on trips together
and like always spending Thanksgiving
together like that's really different
from that's an acquaintance I think we
make this work I don't think so okay so
let's say it is Isaac right and like
stop see him now mm-hmm all of a sudden
ten years later he looks like Jason
Momoa he's like 64 not even the same
Isaac any more weird cuz I've seen since
he was a kid like you know you're gonna
be looking at a guy that's six for a
little bit he's probably got that same
smile the same Isaac smile but Jason
Momoa all around then they come over
like hey TIFF are you mom now we're
Isaac Gordy has you like this parent you
do like the Four Seasons bedroom so
weird different or false
haha asking did this guy seems kind of
salty to create a whole excel sheet in a
graph just to [ __ ] point out like
you're ousting somebody like he's all
molester that's what they're kind of oh
yeah it just seems like he's jealous
like look at this guy getting all the
top-notch girls and he gets to just
throw away the girls at like it says a
lot about his own like mental state if
he only wants to date rules that are
this young and like what does that say
bottle I don't think it's the criteria I
think he likes beautiful women
but here's nothing there's another thing
I need to mention that there there were
witnesses that they did say that he was
at this party where they were like it
was like 40 year olds and up and there
were so many beautiful women and he
didn't talk to a single ones it's not
beautiful to have tips it does even
Giselle is like she's in her forties but
she's not beautiful name a beautiful
woman over 30 [ __ ] Angeline Jolie
construes not I would let her do
terrible things to me I just love her so
much but everyone will say Oh her prime
was the 90s
or whatever her prime is Laura Croft
Tomb Raider one you know where these
young girls are more easily impressed
that's what I'm yeah it's because what
series 25 like so are reading married he
doesn't want to deal with that right
young girls are easier to impress that's
why older guys go for younger girls
because if you have a [ __ ] younger girls
are fun though yeah exactly if you have
a [ __ ] ass card because they don't have
any problems so there's they're just one
up they just want to play all the time
yeah shitty car you live with roommates
that in this shitty house it's like it's
so cool listen to are you against people
getting new cars if your cars li a
little older cuz you know it's getting a
little rickety did you seem like the one
that's the most against it yeah you see
you know why I think it bothers me more
because it's too similar to my own
father
my own dad is yeah but he's dating
underage he's dating people that are all
seven figure eight figure like they're
it's one hour couple share some people
young people are looking at these chicks
they're not they're just like oh my guys
18 it's like it's an 18 year old mogul
businesswoman yeah it's not like people
are Kelly you're not a normal person
they're not looking at the whole picture
make their own what like that their own
brand that they're gonna always yeah
every single one of those chicks are
Kelly they are they I'm sure they
already have LLC's since they're like 15
or so they could get any man that they
want and they just happen it does look
their business woman but I just happen
to have finances that's what it but he's
a truck oil to that business woman yeah
you say fine asses or finances finances
oh but both
don't want me stealing my mansu's in
finance I have 50% IP do you know I came
up with all of it okay fine whatever
fine [ __ ] it whatever we're not gonna
make much of a fine I think it's creepy
when someone is a predator or there's
some type of Power Balance yeah there's
an imbalance right or like our Kelly
situation he's taking advantage of how
they look at him and how these girls
don't have anything and their chicks are
off the street they're just regular
people he's dealing with other fellow
CEO you compare then obviously like I'm
not comparing I'm just talking about
like the view that people are viewing it
the circumstance is completely different
so strong confident women who wouldn't
let someone pee on them for yeah see
like these are the higher class or if
you look at all of the other people the
other caliber of people that these
chicks are dating they're all also of
Leo's caliber power couple yeah it's
like Tom Tom Brady dissolved that
bunches with Tom Brady Blake Lively went
with Ryan Reynolds like they're all
power people and so I don't see any
problem with it Leo's not making nobody
date him all these chicks are are in
relationships with the guys like he's
buying them long-term relationships
the Weisse article that I'm reading off
of it they also mentioned how like now
he has a posse or he's always had like
his posse to go up to women at parties
so he won't actually talk to them he'll
go up to a woman would be like hey can
we get your business card and then he
takes it like his little posse he takes
it back to Leo's and that's how they
contact them but he doesn't even like
interact with them you know what you get
pickup artists for him pickup artists
though if you leo
if you're that Calif you're not gonna
win all you have to do is really let's
go
and then though this book you're not
gonna waste your time you look like you
know a conspiracy I heard about leo is
he's actually gay and these are his
beards lots of experience that's a Tom
Cruise John Travolta thing yeah because
they do mention that every single woman
and anyone that's near him has to sign
NDA's about him no one no one's ever
given an interview about him and one
time this Lily Aldridge she was near
some other girl that was talking about
how
they were like intimate and then Lily
was like she's their word she was like
well I would do that if I was Leo's
Scott Eminem does that like everyone
gets to talk about our relationship all
make people sign India's when they go to
the station just to even get inside of
his house you have to sign it and do it
right if you're at a certain level I
feel like you that's all normal anything
that happens I'm suddenly you guys nd
it's just to make myself feel better
please sign them I'll sign it I'll sign
them I'm saying [ __ ] you know I think I
should to talk about anyways again
exactly you already reveal all your own
[ __ ] yeah just as friends hanging out
with the Logan brothers like if you just
come over to hang out there's an NDA for
each time each time paperwork it's not
likely just walking up to these chicks
and he's like hey Gina hi how are you
yeah how are you Gina 19 yeah see
exactly it's not like he's walking up
and asking their ages and then you're
like I'm 29 and he's like see you later
it's really Google lignin that's how you
get that
no he's just seeing him and he's going
this is [ __ ] hot women holy [ __ ] I'm
on it
imagine they were beards and he was
gonna be awesome I would love to be
appeared to be someone's beard why cuz
you don't have to [ __ ] up man and you
get clout it tend to be your girlfriend
yeah do you not and you get a best
friend at the same time you know like
sex I don't care for sex Oh like I can
just hang up on myself I'm good that's a
lie you told me you loved giving
[ __ ] like I love it when I'm in a
relationship but when I'm out of all I
really care much for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]